você se lembra dos dejetos
esse desvio ficou muito famoso aqui no
brasil nos anos 80 e 90
eu era muito fã desse desenho o meu
personagem predileto era electrónico eu
não sei se vocês se lembram mais
electrónico foi o primeiro cachorro que
já se jackson estiveram antes mesmo do
aço que foi o cachorro mais simbólico
eu não sou moleque crônico porque ele é
fiel
obediente fazer tudo gestos pediu o que
é exatamente contato que o cachorro que
me mantinha na época fazia a mel
uma vez eu pintei ela todo no cantinho
de prata com esperança que ela virasse o
lektronix assim o time me obedecer
só que ao invés de gerar esse cachorro
do futuro
eu acabei levando dois dias de castigo
um mês sem mesada e amel mediana ainda
mais
mas voltando aqui os jetsons este
desenho foi criado nos anos 60 em
visionava como seria a cidade moderna
cidade do futuro essas cidades
inteligentes
essa visão de futuro seria como
deveríamos no ano de 2060 os jetsons
representam esse nosso feitio este
técnico científico que insiste moldar as
nossas visões e das idéias como carros
voadores a base eletrônicas e tubos e
transportadores coisas que a gente não
vê hoje em dia e que raramente vamos ver
nos próximos 40 anos
se formos pensar nas cidades hoje em dia
que estão seguindo esse modelo de cidade
inteligente automaticamente pensaríamos
em cidades como tóquio nova york e são
francisco com um se trouxermos esse
ideal aqui do nosso contexto no brasil
pensaremos em cidades como são paulo mas
em vez de focar na cidade como um todo
focaremos em regiões onde recebe mais
investimentos por exemplo na zona oeste
de são paulo na zona sul do rio
eu até aqui vitória em baixo uma praia
do canto mata da praia e é isso que eu
quero falar com vocês é falar justamente
o outro lado dessa cidade que raramente
é visto como parte dessa cidade
inteligente
se formos levar a nossa situação nossa
realidade e conta as nossas cidades do
futuro apareceram mais com essa foto o
que a cidade que eu te falei
mas você deve estar se perguntando
porque a favela
atualmente nos centros urbanos o texto
da população vive em áreas semelhantes
às da favela
na américa latina a situação um pouco
mais intensa
oitenta por cento da população vive nos
centros urbanos onde os índices de
desigualdade social são os maiores do
mundo
nesses centros urbanos 85 por cento da
população vive regiões com condições
semelhantes na favela
infelizmente quando tivemos a situação
da favela
eu estou me referindo à falta de
saneamento básico falta de acesso à água
tratada difícil acesso à educação à
saúde e à falta de segurança mas a
favela está aqui para ficar
sua população cresce no mundo inteiro
cerca de 7 milhões de habitantes por ano
mantendo assim a maioria dos centros
urbanos é mais do que necessário lógico
pensar atenção nessas áreas não só para
resolver esses problemas que acabei de
dizer mas também porque é de lá que
saíram as diaristas nas domésticas
lojistas pedreiros eletricistas enfim a
mão de obra que irá servir e construir a
nossa cidade do futuro
voltando a falar da cidade do futuro
como é que então vamos a interessar
essas condições para que possamos chegar
às cidades inteligentes
o nosso fetiche técnico científico é que
tem direcionado como vamos seguir essas
peças há evoluções para chegar à cidade
do futuro
porém esse solucione zta tecnológico nos
levar a lugar algum
a nossa fé na tecnologia não deve ser
seguida cegamente
vou dar um exemplo a internet veio para
democratizar o acesso à informação mas
quanto o favelado usa a internet nos
prontificamos pra julgar esse movimento
com uma aula
orkutização da internet ao invés de
promover uma plataforma onde a internet
pudesse ligar diferentes setores de
classe da sociedade
acabamos por amplificar as divisões que
trazemos o mundo offline
portanto não devemos nos virar para a
tecnologia como se fosse uma bala de
pato que vai resolver os problemas
sociais
até porque não foi a tecnologia em causa
desses problemas
esses problemas estão enraizadas em que
suas históricas e sociais muito mais
profundas como é que vamos resolver esse
problema é justamente aí que voltamos à
nossa cidade do futuro inteligente que
são as favelas
o nosso futuro mundano e pra isso é
preciso ver essa realidade com olhos de
quem vive esse dia a dia
enxergar esse velho e novo mundo através
de óleo sem preconceitos e pra isso é
preciso ter o que eu chamo de empatia
social que a capacidade de compreender
mais profundamente as pessoas percebendo
ou vivenciando suas situações de vida e
com um resultado que ganhando percepções
das desigualdades e disparidades
estruturais para conquistar a simpatia a
social é preciso realizar três fatores
um empate individual quem entender o a
situação da pessoa através do olhar dele
a compreensão do contexto ou seja
entendeu o o ambiente da favela ou então
mapear questões sociais que precisam ser
resolvidas através desse novo olhar é
justamente olhando pra favela que
podemos buscar as soluções não só falar
mas para a nossa cidade inteligente já
que nós teremos ficou existir no mesmo
centro urbano e isso algumas sugestões
que podem nos levar até essa cidade
inteligente na favela
a infraestrutura é muito frágil devido à
falta de investimento público e privado
os moradores vivem praticamente uma
cidade quebrada onde preciso engajar
diariamente em práticas de a manutenção
e conserto dessa a infraestrutura são
atos constantes
carinho e cuidado com artefatos que são
necessários e fundamentais para a
sobrevivência de qualquer um afinal
serão os mantenedores e não os
inovadores que criaram a cidade do
futuro
as inovações são desenvolvidas para
serem superadas e descartadas e com a
crise do lixo eletrônico que vivemos
hoje é mais do que necessário saber
reutilizar e manter as nossas
tecnologias porque se essa produção
desacelerado de lixo tóxico irá
comprometer os nossos recursos naturais
como a água eo solo
nós não precisamos de carros autônomos
ou esses carros que dirige sozinho para
nos conduzir as distâncias curtas e e
médias o que a cidade do futuro precisa
de centros ea de vivências ela não
precisa de ruas
preciso de praças e parques onde as
pessoas podem conviver e se relacionar
hoje essas relações são convertidas em
relacionamentos onde haverá integração
social
as cidades do futuro é preciso levar em
consideração os nossos objetivos e
anseios como prioridade no planejamento
urbano onde fóruns aproveiram um espaço
para que possamos debater e servir como
o mercado de idéias onde o processo é
transparente e as idéias e soluções vêm
da gente e não imposta por instituições
e organizações como o governo e um
grande exemplo de um fórum que temos
aqui vitória é no território do bem
realizado pelo ateliê de idéias
portanto a tecnologia pode sim nos
ajudar a alcançar esses objetivos
porém não deve ser visto como a solução
portanto a cidade inteligente não
precisa se preparar para tecnologia e
sim à tecnologia que precisa se adequar
às nossas necessidades
assim as tabelas oferece um espaço onde
designers e políticos podem assim
informar de como é produzir essas
práticas sociais e também como produzir
tecnologias e políticas públicas que vão
promover essas práticas sociais
a indústria também pode aprender e
organizações mais inteligentes baseado
nessas práticas de manutenção com poucos
recursos e também prestando atenção às
ações participativas e à rejeição de
abordagens que são impostas de cima para
baixo
portanto não devemos olhar as favelas
como uma praga do presente e sim devemos
abordá las como uma ecologia sócio
técnica que é único é importante e pode
sim nos ensinar muito a construir um
futuro melhor
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]